careless reckless Thanks I'd look it
right in that fat ugly face averse she's
a slob
like a pig a person who's flat-chested
is very hard to pretend she have a good
body no she have a fat absolutely so you
treat women with respect I can't say
that either michael dukakis is opposed
virtually every defense system we
developed Bush supports the death
penalty for first-degree murderers
Dukakis not only opposes the death
penalty he allowed first-degree
murderers to have weekend passes from
prison and now he wants to be our
commander-in-chief America can't afford
that risk John Kerry has not been honest
about what happened in Vietnam he is
lying about his record I know John Kerry
is lying about his first Purple Heart
because I treated him for that injury
even punishment for abortion it has to
be some form of punishment for President
Johnson on November 3rd the stakes are
too high for you to stay home lots of
famous people lots of famous people lots
and lots of famous people just a ton of
famous people a racist abusive coward
who could permanently damage the fabric
of our society do the math do we really
want to give nuclear weapons to a man
whose signature move is firing firing
firing things